GORAN K. HANSSON: The Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences
has today decided to award
the Sveriges Riksbank
Prize in Economic Sciences
in Memory of Alfred Nobel
to Angus Deaton, for his
analysis of consumption,
poverty, and welfare.
ANGUS DEATON:
Looking back on it,
it seems like a sort of golden
fairytale adventure, in which
it's really hard to
believe it was real,
even from the first phone
call, when they said what
they were giving it to me for.
And I'd always sort
of thought that I
had relatively low
chance of getting it,
because they like to say
they're giving it for one big,
deep thing.
They sort of saw a theme
in this, in terms of it
all being about welfare
and measurement.
There is a theme of that sort,
and that theme has been there
for a very long time.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: I
myself first met Angus shortly
after I joined the Woodrow
Wilson School faculty,
and was immediately
impressed with his leadership
in the school and
his willingness
to tackle important questions.
I am thrilled that this
year's Nobel Prize was awarded
to someone who is
both a great economist
and a great Princetonian.
CECILIA ROUSE: I believe that
Angus Deaton's work and Angus
Deaton is motivated by
public policy in everything
that he does, whether it's
looking at consumption, income
inequality, poverty, that he is
motivated to better understand
the world to make
it a better place.
ANNE CASE: He brings This
curiosity to the question,
and has never lost that.
His sense of wonder
about the world
is, I would say, second to none.
HENRY FARBER: He is one of
the few economists I really
want to emulate,
because he's what I
would call a true intellectual.
He reads voluminously.
He reads everything he
can get his hands on.
So he always has a broad view
of the problem he is working on.
JANET CURRIE: I think
Angus is one of the people
that best embodies a traditional
notion that both data
and theory are very important.
ILYANA KUZIEMKO: Angus' style
of research I think of as
incredibly liberating, to me
as a young assistant professor,
when I came to Princeton.
Both Angus and Anne
just made me feel
like I didn't have to
work on one idea, which I
think is very much Angus' work.
And I think that's sort of
indicative of the way the Nobel
Prize gave Angus an
award for being Angus.
CHRISTINA PAXSON: Angus
approaches problems
in a very distinctive way.
And I guess I would say
he almost approaches them
like a detective.
He comes up with a
very interesting,
important question.
He wants to find out
the answer to it.
He doesn't have any
preconceived notions about what
that answer might be,
and he's as likely
to find something that is
unexpected as something that's
expected.
GORAN K. HANSSON: Dear
Professor Deaton, you
are an optimist, a
skeptic, and a humanist.
And above all, you are an
empiricist, always determined
to confront what we believe
with what we can know, just
like Alfred Nobel.
It is an honor and
a privilege for me
to convey to you, on
behalf of the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences, our
warmest congratulations.
May I now please ask you to step
forward and receive your prize
from His Majesty, the King.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANGUS DEATON: One of my greatest
pleasures in recent years
has been seeing the
subject matter of economics
broaden and expand.
It has not given up its core
themes, its measurement,
or its mathematics, but it
has re-embraced its origins
in history, in psychology,
and political science,
in sociology,
and in philosophy.
It has become a richer
and more humane subject.
ORLEY ASHENFELTER: What
probably makes him exceptional--
and I think maybe the Nobel
committee appreciated--
is that he doesn't leave it
at perfecting or improving economic theory.
He tries to take
that to some data
and use it to explore
the details of what
he's discovered.
ANNE CASE: Angus came
to Princeton in 1983.
And starting with
that Class of 1983,
he has left an indelible print
on a generation of students who
have come through Princeton.
He is a terrific lecturer.
He is crystal clear, and he is
really excited about the work.
And he makes other people
excited about the work.
JANET CURRIE: Angus was one of
my first teachers at Princeton.
So I actually still
remember having
him walk into the classroom.
And I don't know exactly what
I expected, maybe some little
wiry Scotsman.
And this great, huge
bear of a man walked in.
He was taller than
the blackboard.
I was really impressed.
And then of course when
he started to talk,
I was even more impressed.
He gave an absolutely beautiful
course on econometrics.
He was one of my advisers
for my dissertation.
I have known Angus
for a long time.
One characteristic that
stands out, he's very funny.
He's very knowledgeable
about many subjects.
If you had to pick one person to
have dinner with and be certain
that you would not be bored,
he would be a very good person
to pick.
ILYANA KUZIEMKO:
Angus the man, well--
How would I describe Angus?
Probably best not to
talk to him after a game
in which the Yankees lost
in a close situation.
HENRY FARBER: Angus
is completely human.
I mean, he doesn't hide much.
So he lets it all hang out.
And so that makes
him a good friend,
and just a good person
to be around because
for a person of
his accomplishment
to be as natural as he is, to me
is a gift to me, if not to him.
CHRISTINA PAXSON:
I should tell you
that I came to Princeton
University because
of Angus Deaton.
I was a labor economist looking
to turn into a development
economist, and he
was an econometrician
who hadn't been at Princeton
long who wanted to become
a development economist.
And Angus' offer to me
was, come to Princeton,
I'm putting together
a group, and we
can do this, become development
economists, together.
And the span of my
collaboration with Angus
lasted literally decades.
And over that period, we
wrote many papers together,
some of the papers that I
think are the most fun papers
I ever worked on.
And so he was a colleague,
and he has been a teacher,
and he's been just
a tremendous friend.
CECILIA ROUSE: One of the great
things about Angus Deaton
is that he is a great
colleague, he's a great mentor,
he's a good friend.
He's just an overall
wonderful person,
so we couldn't be more thrilled
that the world has finally
recognized, or at least the
Nobel Prize committee has
finally recognized, not only
his contributions to economics,
but that this is really
a wonderful scholar who's
contributed to all of our
intellectual thinking,
and to all of us as a community.
[MUSIC PLAYING]